president biden plans to sign an
executive order on policing today the
second anniversary of george floyd's
murder it comes as a small but growing
number of communities are telling police
not to stop drivers from minor offenses
those include broken tail lights tinted
windows or expired license plates
virginia los angeles philadelphia and
lansing michigan are among the places
that have made those changes but police
human unions have been pushing back and
have even sued adriana diaz went to
lansing to take a look a warning some
viewers may find images in her report
disturbing
i'm stopping you do you have a license
in grand rapids michigan a traffic stop
started over a license plate and ended
with patrick leoyea dead
police escalated for his family of
congolese refugees the death defies
logic
officers are supposed to protect lives
not take them his father told us you
never want a traffic stop to end out in
a death i don't care what they did it's
not a death sentence in our way the city
of lansing michigan and mayor andy shore
are trying something new in 2020 they
banned traffic stops for minor
infractions altogether the goal to avoid
unnecessary escalations racial profiling
and pretextual stops where an officer
uses a minor violation to pull over and
search a car shore says the move could
save lives for both civilians and
officers what's been the pushback that
you've gotten because you're essentially
asking the police not to enforce the law
somewhat our police officers are still
pulling people over but they're doing it
for public safety reasons you know
everything happens so quickly the risk
is worth the reward says lansing police
chief ellery sosby if i pull over a
traffic stop for a busted taillight and
there's not a gun in there and it
escalates into something it's just not
worth it so what are officers telling
you now that you've been instituting
this change i'll be completely honest
it's a it's a hard selling and the
officers were concerned that we were
trying to take tools away from them
according to a new york times
investigation in the last five years at
least 400 unarmed drivers and passengers
have been killed by police during
traffic stops nationwide and black
motorists are over represented
it started over a license plate for
dante wright
philando castile was killed at this
traffic stop the officer later said he
thought castile was pulling out a gun oh
my god please don't tell me he's dead in
another escalation a passenger killed
police officer ella french in chicago
you have to ask yourself what are the
consequences we spoke with chesapeake
police chief kelvin wright who called
the state of virginia's ban a slippery
slope things escalated out of control in
just about any type of call we respond
to which tells me that it is a people
problem chief can ask you a somewhat
personal question yes do you have any
kids i have two sons do you have the
talk with them about how they need to
behave themselves uh when interacting
with law enforcement yes ma'am i tell
them these are the things you do to make
sure that you walk away from an
interaction with a police officer okay
there are ways to conduct traffic stops
and all police interactions and minimize
the potential harm but i think it is a
two-way street
right escalation by police and citizens
is the real problem not traffic stops
in lansing low level stops are down but
black drivers are still
disproportionately pulled over but mayor
shore hopes the ban will improve
relations with police a lot of it is a
trust factor our citizens have to be
able to trust the police for cbs
mornings adriana diaz lansing michigan